Trascrizione:
Il giorno della mia laurea,
il momento di svolta nella mia vita.
Gli anni all'università, per me,
sono stati veramente molto difficili,
e questa è la prima volta
che ne parlo in pubblico.
Emicrania, nausea, mal di pancia costanti.
Avevo un'ansia fortissima
in tutto quello che facevo.
Pensate che non ho preso treni e aerei
per più di dieci anni,
e ho perso il conto delle visite
che ho fatto in ospedale:
visite veramente di tutti i tipi.
Mi sentivo fermo,
in un mondo in continuo movimento:
tutti che viaggiavano,
facevano l'Erasmus, si muovevano,
ed io ero fermo a casa.
Ma c'era una cosa che mi faceva
star bene, immensamente bene,
e quella cosa era giocare ai videogiochi,
da solo o con i miei amici:
mi piaceva tantissimo.
E poi, quando c'è stata l'opportunità
di scrivere una tesi di laurea,
mi è venuta un'idea:
donare senza spendere,
giocando con i videogiochi.
Dovete sapere che ai videogiochi
non ci giochiamo solo noi giovani.
Siamo quasi tre miliardi
di persone nel mondo.
E il mercato dei videogiochi, da solo,
vale più del doppio di quello del cinema
e della musica messi insieme.
Ci giocano anche
i boomer, i nostri genitori,
persone di tutte le età.
E quindi, questa mia passione
per i videogiochi
mi ha portato a sentire dentro
che dovevo fare qualcosa
che avesse impatto nel mondo fuori.
Ma come mi era nata questa idea
di convertire il tempo speso giocando
in donazione agli enti no profit?
Non so se ve la ricordate, Gangnam Style,
la canzone che ci aveva
trapanato le orecchie prima di Despacito.
Avevo letto un articolo che il cantante,
dopo il primo miliardo
di visualizzazioni su YouTube,
aveva ricevuto diversi milioni da Google
per le inserzioni pubblicitarie.
E quindi ho detto: faccio un video,
convinco un milione
di persone a guardarlo,
e tutti i soldi che mi arrivano
li dono in beneficenza.
Convincere un miliardo di persone
a guardare un video non è semplicissimo:
ma la mia passione mi ha detto,
e se fosse un "gioca e dona"?
Ho iniziato a scrivere
una tesi di 700 pagine -
povero il mio professore
che se l'è letta, credo -
e poi, quando dovevo validare questa idea,
ho raccolto questionari in spiaggia
con i miei cuginetti.
Abbiamo comprato delle t-shirt bianche
con scritto, "se compili un questionario,
ti regaliamo un sorriso."
Siamo andati in spiaggia,
a Jesolo o a Caorle,
c'erano circa 30-40 gradi;
ma i miei cuginetti di 12, 13,
14 anni erano felicissimi,
continuano a chiedermi
di andare in spiaggia
a regalare sorrisi in cambio
di questionari della tesi,
quando ormai mi sono
già laureato da qualche anno.
E voglio tornare proprio là,
al giorno della mia laurea.
È il momento in cui sono uscito
dal caos esistenziale -
Quale sarà il mio futuro?
Cosa faccio adesso? -
E sono entrato nel caos,
volutamente, imprenditoriale,
cioè, ho un'idea:
voglio salvare il mondo
giocando con i videogiochi.
Sì, ok, ma com'è che faccio?
E subito dopo essermi laureato,
la prima frase che ho letto
è quella di Elon Musk,
fondatore di Tesla, che dice:
"Fondare un'azienda
è come masticare vetro
guardando l'abisso".
E ho detto: evvai, si parte alla grande!
Ed è proprio lì che subito
mi rendo conto, di cosa?
Che l'idea sì, era bellissima.
Un centodieci e lode in economia
e un bel sorriso trentadue denti;
ma questo non bastava per fare un'azienda,
qualcosa che potesse spiccare il volo.
L'idea, mi sono reso conto subito,
era l'un percento,
era un pezzettino del puzzle,
c'era bisogno di qualcuno che mi aiutasse.
Quindi inizio a raccontare l'idea
a destra e a manca,
ed è lì che, un giorno, mi scrive un ex...
Un giocatore di basket, come me,
al liceo scientifico, come me,
mi dice, "Ciao, io ti voglio aiutare.
Non so come, ma ti voglio aiutare."
Piccolo dettaglio: quella persona, Matteo,
è un ingegnere aerospaziale;
e quindi io, in quel momento,
sì, pensavo prima o poi
di fare uno Space Invaders,
o un gioco dello spazio;
però non dovevo, come Elon Musk,
volare nello spazio,
e quindi dico: va beh, senti,
sai cosa ti dico? Proviamoci.
E quindi partiamo,
sviluppiamo i primi giochi.
Questo è il primo gioco, con la mia testa
che ha preso un sacco di botte sui tubi;
ma siamo partiti,
e poche settimane dopo ci arriva
la chiamata dalla Silicon Valley,
e diciamo: "Oh mamma mia,
dall'America ci chiamano?".
Quindi facciamo una raccolta fondi -
non volevamo chiedere i soldi al papà -
e abbiamo detto:
proviamoci, facciamo qualcosa,
una "gamification" della raccolta fondi,
e quindi, con 20 euro
eri un "king", ti facevamo un video;
con 50 euro eri un campione,
ti mandavamo una cartolina.
La raccolta fondi va benissimo,
abbiamo migliaia di condivisioni;
e salpiamo per l'America.
Per me è stato un sogno incredibile:
erano dieci anni che non prendevo
un treno, un aereo
e mi sono trovato lì
a mettere piede in America.
È stato qualcosa di straordinario,
che avevo sempre sognato.
Quindi l'entusiasmo era veramente alto.
Ma prima di partire, c'era una cosa
che era un po' più bassa:
erano i soldi per partire.
Avevamo fatto la raccolta fondi, sì,
abbiamo guardato
tutti i possibili appartamenti.
San Francisco è una delle città
più care al mondo:
un affitto sei sui tremila dollari,
e una pizza margherita 32 euro.
Quindi abbiamo detto:
adesso cosa facciamo?
E quindi iniziamo, guardiamo,
troviamo una signora che ero sicuro
che dovevamo andare là da lei
e ci dice: "Ho un problema,
devo andare in India
a fare un giro in mongolfiera
di tutta l'India,
e ho bisogno di qualcuno
che mi badi al gatto".
E noi, "Lo facciamo subito noi,
facciamo cat-sitting,
però ci devi fare uno sconto
del 60% sulla casa".
Lei dice, " Va bene",
E quindi badiamo a BC,
che l'ultimo giorno scopriamo
che BC stava per "black cat",
gli davamo da mangiare,
la mattina, e poi scappava.
Quindi entriamo in America, è un sogno,
e ci rendiamo conto fin da subito
che c'era bisogno di creatività,
e intraprendenza,
in quello che dovevamo fare.
Io voglio raccontarvi di Facebook.
Noi volevamo entrare
a raccontare la nostra idea,
e la prima cosa che abbiamo fatto
è stata di iniziare a contattare
delle persone che lavorano lì.
Non abbiamo avuto nessuna risposta.
Abbiamo provato alla reception dicendo:
"Ciao, siamo dei ragazzi italiani
con una start-up di gaming, vogliamo -"
Hanno detto: "No,
quella è la porta, uscite".
Stavamo uscendo, mettiamo piede fuori,
troviamo un telefono per terra e diciamo,
"Vabbè, sarà uno dei telefoni
dei dipendenti".
Lo prendiamo, lo stiamo
per consegnare in reception,
e in quel momento pensiamo:
aspetta, l'unica cosa che si può fare,
con un telefono bloccato con il pin,
è fare un video.
Quindi lo prendiamo,
e in un video diciamo:
"Ciao, siamo quelli
che hanno trovato il telefono,
se vuoi sdebitarti facci entrare
in Facebook, facci parlare."
Nessuna risposta,
nessuno, nessuno, nessuno,
nei giorni successivi, settimane.
Guardiamo il telefono e vediamo
che c'era una foto di noi fuori
che abbiamo detto, è simpatica,
c'è il nostro sorrisino,
e diciamo: facciamo un esperimento.
Proviamo a caricarlo
su un altro social, LinkedIn,
e facciamo questo esperimento di:
vuoi vedere se,
mettendo il like a dei ragazzi
che fanno il simbolo del like
fuori dall'azienda dei like,
il post possa diventare virale
e vuoi che non becchiamo
uno dei 10.000 dipendenti
dell'headquarter a san Francisco?
Passano cinque, sei ore,
centinaia e centinaia di consigliati,
e il giorno successivo
pioveva veramente tanto;
ma eravamo dentro con la
responsabile gaming di Facebook,
e là abbiamo capito
che quella volta ci è andata bene, sì,
la punta dell'iceberg,
quella dei successi;
ma sotto ci sono tanti,
tanti, tanti insuccessi.
Ma quando sei veramente motivato
a raggiungere il tuo obiettivo,
allora te ne freghi, e vai, e corri,
e sia io che Matteo,
da ex cestisti, giocatori di basket,
abbiamo, come esempio,
sua altezza reale, Michael Jordan,
e una frase che ha detto
rappresenta al meglio
perché successo e fallimento
non sono due opposti,
ma il fallimento è uno step
per raggiungere il successo.
Jordan dice: "Nella mia vita
ho sbagliato più di 9000 tiri.
Ho perso quasi 300 partite.
26 volte i miei compagni
mi hanno affidato il tiro decisivo,
e l'ho sbagliato.
Ho fallito molte volte,
ed è per questo
che alla fine ho vinto tutto".
Quindi, ogni giorno, in quello che faccio,
mi ripeto sempre,
potrà sembrare molto banale,
che "Se ci provo,
ho l'un percento di farcela.
Se non ci provo, lo zero."
E quindi, se è qualcosa
che veramente voglio raggiungere,
ci provo.
Perché uno è maggiore di zero,
non ci vuole una laurea.
E quindi veramente dico,
perché non provarci.
Perché è giusto pensarci,
rifletterci, studiare, eccetera;
però a un certo punto
bisogna anche provarci, fare qualcosa.
E infatti, io credo fortemente
che nessuno è mai dimagrito
restando sul divano,
leggendo libri su come dimagrire:
a un certo punto hai capito
che devi fare attività fisica,
ti allacci le scarpe e inizi a correre.
Nelle start-up si dice,
"Done is better than perfect",
cioè fatto è meglio di perfetto.
Quindi non possiamo star lì,
a sperare che arrivi il momento giusto:
dobbiamo partire e provare,
un passettino alla volta,
che nel mio caso mi ha portato
dalla tesi alla Silicon Valley,
ma che comunque, anche durante
il mio caos esistenziale,
mi ha permesso di uscire
e ripartire a prendere treni e aerei,
perché - io abito in un paese
che si chiama "Paese": la fantasia!
Le prime volte che volevo
ripartire a viaggiare
non ho detto subito,
"Faccio Paese - San Francisco":
ho fatto Paese - Treviso
in treno, quattro minuti.
Le prime volte non andava per niente bene:
ma io ci provavo e ci riprovavo.
Poi, quando è andata bene Paese - Treviso,
e ho fatto Paese - Venezia,
29 minuti, regionale veloce.
E lì le primissime volte non andava bene,
ma ci provavo, ci provavo
finché poi ho fatto Paese - Milano,
Paese - San Francisco.
Quindi è stata un'emozione straordinaria,
ma non è arrivata da un momento all'altro,
è stato un passo, un passo, un passo.
E come - ascoltavo sempre
un discorso motivazionale
ogni volta che facevo questo tentativo,
di Al Pacino, nel film
"Ogni maledetta domenica",
dice: "Un centimetro alla volta.
Quando alla fine andrai
a sommare tutti quei centimetri
vedrai la differenza
tra la vittoria e la sconfitta",
Quindi, veramente un passo dopo l'altro.
Ora voglio chiudere dandovi una mano
con cinque consigli
che credo siano
molto importanti per agire.
Il primo: l'ho vissuto sulla mia pelle,
ve lo consiglio veramente -
trovare un compagno.
Da soli è veramente difficile.
Nella buona e nella cattiva sorte,
avere qualcuno che può aiutare
è davvero importante,
perché a vincere non sono
le idee, ma le persone.
Se io 17 anni fa avessi avuto
l'idea di creare un social
dove, quando una persona
metteva un contenuto interessante,
si metteva un pollicione alto,
non è detto che sarei riuscito
a creare Facebook.
Quindi, le persone come prima cosa.
La seconda: siate curiosi
di ascoltare qualcuno,
che sia un amico, un parente, un mentore,
qualcuno che vi possa dire
come fare quella cosa.
Spesso non agiamo perché abbiamo la paura
di sapere cosa può succedere.
Quindi confrontarci con qualcuno
che quella cosa l'ha già fatta
ci può aiutare molto.
Nelle start-up, a noi dicono sempre
che dobbiamo correre, correre;
ma ogni tanto è giusto fermarci
per confrontarci con qualcuno,
perché ha poco senso correre velocemente,
se si va nella direzione sbagliata.
La terza è non aspettare
il momento perfetto.
Qua siamo tutti giovani, e quindi io dico:
se volete partire,
aprire un canale Tik Tok,
scrivere un libro, far qualcosa
che vi ossessiona, che volete fare,
partite, fatelo, contate fino a tre e via.
La quarta: pensare subito
al piano B, C, D.
Avete visto, anche con Facebook,
che noi non ci siamo fermati al fatto
che nessuno ci aveva risposto:
siamo andati avanti,
perché volevamo raggiungere l'obiettivo
e quindi avete fino alla Z -
A, B, C, D, F, G...
Poi, nel momento in cui arrivate
al piano Z e non funziona,
cambiate strada, nel senso
che non è la cosa migliore da fare.
E l'ultimo che vi voglio dare,
con una visione un po' diversa
di quello che è il mio mondo,
è quello di non arrendervi.
È una cosa che vi hanno detto
all'infinito, "Non arrenderti":
Io ve la voglio portare
con un punto di vista diverso,
quello dei videogiochi.
Quando giocate a un videogioco,
fate una partita
e magari il primo livello vincete subito;
ma quando inizia a essere
il quinto, sesto, settimo livello,
eh, non è semplice vincere subito.
Quindi fate una partita, perdete;
un'altra, perdete.
E quindi c'è questo fallimento
che viene accettato nel mondo virtuale,
meno nel mondo reale,
ma che è normalissimo
nel mondo dei videogiochi.
E provate a pensare a un gioco
dove, ogni volta che giocate,
vincete sempre.
Che noia!
Quindi, veramente,
il mondo dei videogiochi a me ha insegnato
che non bisogna arrendersi,
che bisogna provare;
e che, con questi cinque punti,
io spero veramente di avervi dato
cinque consigli pratici,
spero di avervi dato una mano.
E spero che voi, ora,
possiate afferrare questa mano
per correre, per non star fermi,
e ricordarvi che, comunque vada,
ne vale la pena.
Grazie.